moment très important parce qu'on va
élire nous
représentants au sénat le sénat est une
chambre importante notamment pour les
collectivités locales et paris est une
collectivité locale quand bien même il
s'agit de la capitale de la france donc
aujourd'hui je crois que voilà tout le
monde est ici réunis pour pour ce moment
démocratique intense pour moi c'est
effectivement le bout d'un cycle
électoral qui était aussi marquée par un
autre moment très important pour paris
qui a été notre victoire aux jo les
élections nationales se termine
aujourd'hui avec cette élection
sénatoriale
et là il reste pour ce qui est des
mandats des mères en france et donc pour
le mien un peu moins de trois ans mais
donc nous sommes à mi mandat
donc ça va être aussi un moment plus
local où on va pouvoir se projeter je
vais revenir devant les parisiens pour
présenter le bilan de ce mandat
dans quelques semaines j'attendais
effectivement que le cycle nationale
soit passé pour revenir à quelque chose
de plus locale qui rythment aussi la vie
de nos concitoyens